this is not your way
this is mine
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
dude what's going on with you how are
things man man i love the setup back
there look at that stuff
that's home studio yeah
yeah all the camera gear back there you
know you got to do it
we were sitting a few years ago
robertson key chatting about the
industry
crazy rich asians
and now you are one of the most iconic
characters of the latter 20th century on
film
how does this feel like it's crazy isn't
it um and and you know the weird thing
bobby was like it wasn't that all too
long ago it was probably what three
three years ago
um 2018 was when crazy rich came out so
maybe 2017.
um
but it's it's been a long long graft i
think you know we've kept in contact uh
throughout this entire time and i've
shared with you some of my experiences
with with hollywood and and making these
types of movies and things
but this one was really special this one
was uh was a real dedication
not only sort of mentally but physically
we had to be able to do all these stunts
ourselves we had to sort of put
ourselves
in a position where we could complete
all of this choreography make snake eyes
the most badass he could possibly be
um and so it was yeah it's been a hell
of a ride man and i can't
hear it with everybody okay let's talk
about that for a second because i mean
taking on a iconic role like this
obviously requires the training as you
mentioned but it's also the fan base
you know because they in their own right
i mean they look at these characters
like biblical icons in a lot of ways oh
yeah and snake eyes has got a very
interesting back story so what did you
want to bring as henry to snake eyes
that we haven't seen before
i think a sense of uh humanity i think
what we had seen we'd seen the operator
and the uh
the the badass ninja the guy that uh is
the best fighter in the room but we've
never seen we've never seen the
motivations behind uh the decisions that
he's had to make the tough choices uh
the the mistakes of
following the wrong sorts of people um
and that's what we see in this origin
movie we see the man before the mask
we see him struggle with identity and
there's something we all go through
and sometimes you have to make those
really bad mistakes to understand and
realign yourself uh to a greater good
and that's exactly where we find our
snake eyes
pre-arashikage pre-mask pre-joe's
um and he's hurt he's broken um he's had
one hell of a life so far um and so it's
really interesting to see how he picks
himself up from that interesting you say
that because i mean obviously prior to
this part of your career you are a very
well-known travel host around the region
and i mean you've seen the worst of the
worst from people the best of the best
you've seen all these different
countries now do you take some of that
experience and you bring it into let's
say a character snake eyes where you
know vengeance and loss and pain come
into play
no a hundred percent i mean um
you can look at
you know my time spent with uh channel
news asia which you're very familiar
with and and spending right in in places
like tacloban or or smoky mountain in
the philippines and not understanding
that these
uh orphans have to fend for themselves
they have to be able to feed themselves
and they have to do things
uh which aren't savory to be able to
kind of support and that's something
that we find sort of snake guys he's
from a very young age he's been on his
own had to go through the the school of
hard knocks um so to be able to
one have had experience in talking to to
those types of people who have lived
that through
their real real sort of lives to be able
to kind of soak that in and and channel
that into a character i think it's it's
such a gift
uh that i came into acting a lot later
on in my career uh since sort of
experiencing so much of that um and and
hopefully being able to sort of pick out
certain sort of characteristics that
i've that i've come across for certain
roles okay i got one last question here
they want me to wrap it up one last
question did you keep morning light
bobby i wish i did
i i i
wrote my name on like
one of the things i wish um but no it's
you know there was one hero sword um and
it was beautifully crafted handcrafted
must have took some poor sold like hours
and hours days of on days
to create the sword the last filming day
was in japan so for me to be able to be
like yoink i'll take it i wouldn't be
able to get back to america in the first
place so they'd be like why
samurai sword in your luggage
so i'd have to
but i'm snake eyes
um it wouldn't work itself but um but
i'm i'm looking forward to the day that
uh that paramount uh gift me my own
morning light that i can hang up in
pride uh of place in my home so we'll
we'll be waiting for that day
i'll be waiting for that video call too
all right man thanks a lot take care
take care bobby
you